Speaker 1: So there continues to be something very
wrong with many of the reporters regularly in the
White House press briefing room just determined
to ask ridiculous questions of Jen Psaki.
And in this segment, we're going to look at
two clips. One is Steve Portnoy from CBS News
now with Steve Portnoy does is less about Steve,
and it's more about something many reporters have
been doing in corporate media since the Russian
invasion of Ukraine started. Then we'll look at
Peter Doocy, who is kind of a different
type of character in these situations,
asking different types of questions, but
they're all absurd. So first question
Steve Portnoy from CBS News ask Jen Psaki
Why is the United States not pushing
for like a real world war against Russia at
this point in time? And there seems to be,
and I think we know why, a real desire among many
in corporate media to see that happen, to see
what's happening with Russia and Ukraine boil over
into a true world war. And Jen Psaki does some
good things here, including asking specifically,
what exactly is it you would like to see? Take a
Speaker 3: look. Why shouldn't the
images of the atrocities from bloodshed
compel a worldwide unified coalition?
Speaker 2: Kinetic response? You mean a military
war? Tell me more about what you mean for
Speaker 3: a military response
led by the United States and the
Speaker 2: international partners
as in bringing military troops on the
ground from the United States and Naito.
Speaker 3: Well, the president
described outrageous things you
call the atrocities you've said. Perhaps we
should brace ourselves for worse. Why not?
Speaker 2: I think what the president's objectives
and his responsibility is to make decisions that
are in the interests of the United States and
the national security of the United States and
the American people. And that is not to go to war
with Russia. It is to do everything in our power
to hold them accountable, to support efforts
through international systems, to do exactly that
and to provide military assistance, security
assistance and support to the Ukrainian people
and the Ukrainian government. That's exactly what
we're doing. But it is not in our interests or in
the interests of the American people for us
to be in a war with Russia. Go ahead. So.
Speaker 1: I I don't I don't even know if
Steve Portnoy personally has this view,
but much of the corporate media has decided,
probably correctly, if you look at history,
that if there was really like a full scale war
against Russia or against Russia in Ukraine,
maybe better said that it would be great for
corporate media ratings. And it's probably true.
It's probably true. I mean, if it bleeds, it
leads. Conflict is good in general for corporate
media. And so it's not just Steve Portnoy,
that's the clip that we're looking at here.
But many in right wing media have been
asking both Joe Biden and Jen Psaki
questions like they're in corporate media
have been asking Jen Psaki and Joe Biden,
were you too quick to rule out some major
escalation? Boots on the ground, sending
troops in drones, whatever. Um, do you think that
you're giving Putin? You're emboldening Putin
by actually saying what you're not willing to
do or whatever the case may be? Do you regret
not taking a harder position and they seem to
just want the biggest possible war? They seem
almost incredulous that Joe Biden doesn't want
to do that, and I commend Joe Biden for that.
We can have a debate and it can be a hearty
debate, and it can be a good faith debate
about what would have been the right things
to do and when when it comes to Russia and
Ukraine going back, we can talk about Crimea
in 2014. That's that's fair. That's fair game.
We can talk about continued occupation of the
Donetsk and Luhansk regions of Ukraine by Russia
while Trump was president.
These are all legitimate things.
But generally speaking, Joe Biden has
handled the situation pretty well. He's
provided a ton of support. Military aid
training to Ukrainian soldiers in Poland.
Drones has even sent over. So if you want Joe
Biden to help, he's done it. And if you don't
want Joe Biden to get us quote into another
war, as has become a popular talking point
on the left and right and generally speaking,
a talking point I agree with, I don't want war.
He has set a line which is we're not getting boots
on the ground, but the corporate media seems to be
desperate, not because they care geopolitically.
I don't think Steve Portnoy and all these people
have geopolitical motivations. It's just about
what's good for corporate media. So that's number
one. I hope Biden stands completely firm on no
boots on the ground. Separately, we have Peter
Doocy and Peter Doocy asks Jen Psaki, would Joe
Biden support appointing a special counsel to
investigate his own son, Hunter Biden? Yeah. Let's
look at that clip and then we'll talk about that
Speaker 3: on another topic. A lot of stories
about Hunter Biden surfacing this week,
so to ensure the independence of the
investigation, would the president support
the appointment of his special counsel?
Speaker 2: Well, first, the president has
never had a conversation with the Department
of Justice about any investigations into any
member of his family. He said that during the
campaign, and he will continue to abide by that.
So I point the Department of Justice for
any additional steps they would take.
They would make those decisions independently.
Speaker 3: Is there any concern that they're not
going to be necessarily seen as being able to make
the decisions independently of the White House?
Chief of staff is out saying that the president
is confident his son did not break the law.
Speaker 2: Well, that's something the president
has said and certainly we would echo. But in the
same answer to that question, Peter, during an
interview this week on the ABC, Ron Klain also
said the Justice Department is independent
and they will make their own decisions.
Speaker 3: And the president has said that
he never spoke to his son about his overseas
business dealings. Is that still the case? Yes.
Speaker 1: So again, I had a conversation here in
Las Vegas earlier with Farron Cousins from Ring
of Fire, and we talked a little about a little
bit about Hunter Biden. I believe that Joe Biden
is doing the exact right thing when it comes to
Hunter Biden, and he's doing what he promised to
do. He is not getting involved and trying to stop
the investigation into Hunter Biden's business
dealings in 2018. Presidents shouldn't on the one
hand, presidents shouldn't try to get the Justice
Department to investigate anybody in particular,
and Joe Biden is doing that, and he could. There's
plenty of people from the Trump era that Joe
Biden could be going to the Justice Department in
saying, Hey, this is something you should really
be looking at. Investigate this charge, people.
Maybe he's not doing that. That's correct. And
he's also not trying to obstruct the investigation
into Hunter Biden. That is exactly what Joe Joe
Biden should have no involvement. And as I've
said before, I couldn't care less about Hunter
Biden. If Hunter Biden committed crimes, charge
him. If Hunter Biden is found guilty of crimes,
punish him. It just has nothing to do with
Joe Biden's administration. And there's also a
confusion happening between the investigation into
Hunter Biden and the laptop. The investigation
doesn't have anything to do with a laptop, and a
lot of people also don't seem to understand that.
Reporters just really making fools of themselves
every single day in that press briefing room.